I started dancing in 2012 2015 I like be
became like professional is fast forward
to 2019 that's when Tik Tok came out and
the first week I hopped on I gained like
a million followers in a week holy
the first week can you teach us a class
yeah and every week after that I kept
gaining a million a million a week by
the time I moved out it was like May
2020 it had like 25 million what do you
have now 502 God damn that's a small
country bro I know it's it's wild you're
more than South Korea followers on Tik
Tok doesn't even matter as much though
anymore cuz it's all Chinese no cuz a
video doesn't go viral it won't go viral
like you'll have like a base set of
views I see what's your base set if it's
like a bad video two to 400,000 views
what the that's a huge disparity though
if you got 50 million but that also
means every video he posts all of
Bakersfield watches it oh yeah
Bakerfield Fresno Mesto Yuka dude all of
youa dang